one of the hottest trends right now is
the tie-dye and kayla cooper from
joanne's stores is back
to show us how to create this wearable
art with a valentine's day
twist hi kayla i love tie-dye so much
i'm so excited to try this how do we do
this how do we say i love you with some
color
okay so this is a really cool project
we're gonna go ahead and start with our
blank
t-shirt we're gonna fold it in half like
so
okay we're going to take our little
half heart template and we're just going
to line that straight edge
up with that folded edge all right got
that right in the middle
this is easy stuff white t-shirt piece
of paper that's half a heart
gotcha you're gonna take your washable
marker and then just go ahead and trace
around
that part okay let's
my grade school skills are coming back
to haunt me
right and then we're at we're using
washable markers so that way at the end
of the project you won't even split
oh cool okay yeah
so this won't be part of the finished
design
now when you're done tracing that heart
out you're going to take your two rubber
bands
you're going to take one of them all
right and you're just
pinch along the line so you're going to
try to line up the line
and just kind of continue to pinch it
together
so it looks a little bit like this
you've got the little little uh rubber
bands there
pinched together yeah yeah yeah so
it's gonna be like that and then you're
just gonna tie the rubber band
on that red line that just lined up
there okay
i love the magic of tv because we have
all the steps ready to go here
there you go right so then when you're
done with that
you're just gonna go ahead and dye it
like you had it and i'm
gonna i have this great tie-dye kit that
we got at joann this tulip a one-step
tie-dye kit so it's very easy it comes
with the gloves it comes with
all the the different colored dyes so
this is perfect so we just take this and
then we put it on the t-shirt
yeah so you're actually going to use the
diluted dye and it's going to go on that
middle part
that that um part you just tied off in
the very beginning
and then you're going to take the darker
dye and you're going to put it
on the end of the project
like so okay make sure you get it all
over
make sure you're gonna part here
because that's gonna be this part on the
t-shirt oh okay so you used all the
different colors
yes absolutely love it when you're dying
all of that you just put it either in a
plastic bag
or wrap it in um some some um
wrap there okay you know off to the side
because it's gonna need to sit for about
six to eight hours for the dye to set
and then you'll have this
look at mine i did such a good job right
you did an amazing job i love it
we're gonna get your oh yours looks
better than mine but i
these are great thank you so much kayla
if you need any
information on how to make your own
tie-dye check out joanne they have
everything and jc i'm going to support
my new shirt and send it back to you
i love the new shirt valen